4 fois plus de sécheresse une
multiplication des feux de forêt ou des
cyclones voilà à quoi pourrait
ressembler la France en 2100 vivre avec
4 degrés de plus un scénario pessimiste
mais réaliste selon les experts pour
préparer au mieux chaque Français à ces
changements le gouvernement lance une
consultation publique vous dites qu'il
faut s'attendre à un réchauffement de 4
degrés à l'horizon 2100 4 degrés à 2100
est-ce que c'est un crash scénario
est-ce que c'est réaliste est-ce que ça
pourrait être pire que quatre degrés ça
pourrait être pire nous sommes le 2 août
2050 demain l'épisode de canicule se
poursuit il fera 42 à Lille 37 à Brest
45 à Bordeaux et jusqu'à 48 à Nîmes
ce bulletin météo du futur n'a rien
d'une invention il a été conçu par les
prévisionnistes du service climatologie
de Météo France des chercheurs qui
surveillent en permanence l'évolution du
climat l'objectif est ambitieux en ces
temps la France doit baisser ses
émissions de CO2 de 45% pour passer de
408 millions de tonnes et mises
aujourd'hui à 270 millions en 2030 mais
après deux heures de présentation les
ONG espérait plus de concrets ce qu'on
va faire sur trafic à rien comment on va
rendre accessible les véhicules
électriques ou le train aux personnes
qui ont des bas revenu comment on va
aussi rediriger l'élevage vers des
élevages durable tout ça on attend les
précisions dans les prochains mois si la
France va se réchauffer partout c'est au
tour de la vallée du Rhône que les
changements seront les plus intenses et
rapides à Annecy Lyon Avignon les
journées et les nuits anormalement
chaudes vont se multiplier d'ici 30 ans
Lyon par exemple subite en moyenne 14
nuits caniculaires chaque année en 2050
leur nombre augmentera en moyenne
jusqu'à 35 imaginez plus d'un mois à
suffoquer même la nuit
[Rires]
la région Flandre a lancé un concours à
qui arrachera le plus de béton regardez
avec ce clip plein d'humour comme seuls
les Belges savent le faire elle
encourage les habitants à casser le
béton à enlever les dalles de leurs
jardins l'objectif c'est de verdir les
villes pour que les plantes et les
insectes puissent revenir on pourrait
presque en prendre de la graine ah si
les images de on a vu les bouteilles de
rosé c'était pas tout à fait le même
sujet
maintenant nous allons pouvoir passer à
l'époque suivante
pour moi le procès doit se faire
immédiatement aussi immédiat c'est en
quelques heures et terminer ses
perpétuités directes ce monsieur Hanouna
remplisse le snipe de ces chroniqueurs
de nouilles tiède chacun fait ce qu'il
veut mais une présentation aussi
vulgaire de la justice Nyon toutes les
règles qui sont les nôtres que notre
société a mis des siècles à élaborer non
[Musique]
bonjour
on va lui demander d'attendre là le
temps que on a eu la décision du
magistrat du magistrats
ok donc là les policiers nous ont
demandé de rester dans la voiture en
attendant que le substitut du procureur
du Havre arrive pour fouiller notre
véhicule alors la voilà donc Éric
dupont-mérity déjà les nouilles elles
étaient pas chaudes donc il revoit
l'émission donc il me parle d'un truc
qui lâche moi jamais dû voir Eric
Dupond-Moretti donc il vient donc parler
à la télévision de ça donc c'est pas
comme il trouve le temps bravo à lui bah
si s'il peut me moi franchement j'ai mon
habitude on dit on a un emploi du temps
de ministre maintenant quand tu dis on
appelait un emploi du temps de mie ça
veut dire qu'il faut rien de la journée
c'est là qu'on prend conscience que
c'est quand même un site très très
sensible ici ils ont pas du tout envie
qu'on en parle et qu'on le film
nous restons une heure au bord de la
route au pied de l'usine
ça y est la magistrate est arrivée donc
elle nous a prévenu qu'elle allait
fouiller notre véhicule je précise que
c'est un véhicule de location je pense
qu'il a jamais vu une émission il part
ici que les nouilles il a dû entendre ça
dans un dîner dans un Parisien et
Eric Dupond-Moretti vraiment on va
l'envoyer le coffret de TPMP comme ça il
pourra un petit peu rigoler parce que je
le sens pas non plus dans la darka total
c'est pas le genre de mec tu te dis Eric
Dupond-Moretti ouais on va faire une
barquard c'est pas genre on te dit à qui
a la soirée il y a du pomon qui ah
darka lui c'est vrai qu'il adore
vous avoir et il a même dit à plusieurs
fois dans l'émission c'est votre ami
c'est quoi être l'ami de Cyril Hanouna
un privilège un privilège c'est à dire
que vous en moi honnêtement c'est un
génie d'accord la première fois que moi
je vous le dis avant mon premier livre
je ne connaissais pas la télé j'ai pas
la télé chez moi je l'ai vu je me suis
dit c'est un génie de la télé vraiment
c'est un modèle de réussite il y a une
règle c'est sur sept jours tu as le
droit de réduire les images parce que
c'est du droit de citation etc donc sur
7 jours c'était des images qui date de 7
jours tu as le droit de les prendre eux
tranquille ils vont prendre des images
il y a deux trois mois il nous appelle
même pas donc il diffuse les images je
vous explique vous allez recevoir la
note demain ça va être salé vous le dis
parce que c'est 10000 euros la minute et
toute minute démarrer c'est une minute
qui doit être payé donc vous avez des
images de 4 secondes c'est 10000 donc
vous avez pris 10 images c'est 200000 je
vous le dis tout de suite c'est
probablement un service de sécurité du
site qui a contacté la police
donc là notre matériel on le revoit plus
avant combien de temps
avant un moment un moment quelques jours
un moment quelques mois
d'accord ok bon
c'est super line un avis sur votre
partenaire de voyage temporel grande
classe non à mon avis on va pas s'amuser
avec elle et j'ai l'impression qu'elle a
un balai dans les fesses
bon tu es belle mais t'es pas que belle
tu vois souvent les belles filles elles
sont vides des coquilles vides toi tu es
une coquille remplie tu sais moi j'adore
en été les pâtes aux moules c'est la
moule dans mes spaghettis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'était ton genre de alors
pas du tout de base c'est le style
physique non non on est rentré à l'hôtel
et qu'il a enlevé
songé on veut pas alors moi je veux bien
savoir combien de choses
[Musique]
il a parfois des poutres apparentes le
plafond
le plafond
c'est cela oui